[Music]
hi my name is Brent hood
I received a Sagar SAR grant to look at
sustainable shrimp the idea less is to
raise them in an environment where we
could source all the components so that
we could raise an all-natural a
naturally raised product what we have
here I got my hands on what's called a
bio filter this helps control the
chemical composition of the water that's
in the pool or the shrimp are here we
have the solar panels these provide
power to the pump there's an air pump
and there's also the water pump that
causes water to flow through the bio
filter here and of course we have the
pool inside the pool there are series of
substrates these are collections of
frames that have been covered with mesh
that allow the shrimp to actually get
away from the other shrimp so they have
their own space to grow we feed twice a
day once in the morning once in the
afternoon we use aqua max 1000 it's a
sinking fish fry pelletized feed that
has a high protein content and so those
are I think the primary components
you're probably asking yourself yeah so
I go and I do all this well how do we
get out of it well these shrimp grow
really large but they need a long
growing period so if you have at least a
hundred days you can raise shrimp these
shrimp will end up being about somewhere
between a number 18 to a number 14
shrimp
backyard shrimping calm is the website
that we set up with this project with
the idea that if you were interested in
doing this in your backyard you could
actually see the firm details when that
site is complete what we are going to
provide is an itemized cost per item so
you'll be able to look at your budget
also a time frame there are certain key
benchmarks on the dates that you want to
make sure you have certain places in
place are certain things in place there
will also be the source for the juvenile
so you probably won't want to try to
erase them as a nursery environment but
there are a couple places where you can
actually get the juveniles which the
spot you want to stock typically you're
going to stock those at about a thousand
at the beginning of your season
typically you'll have a eighty percent
return which means you get eight hundred
and so eight hundred shrimp at just
under 2 ounces of piece will give you a
fairly decent return both for your
family to enjoy and honestly because
everything we've done is all-natural
you'd be able to market that to people
who are concerned about the sourcing for
their shellfish
[Music]
[Applause]